[Music]
hello and welcome everyone to the
closing ceremony of the 2020 cares cup
my name is Alejandro Ramirez and it's a
pleasure to be with all of you chess has
been a game a sport an art how are you
want to see it that's deeply rooted in
tradition and tradition is something
that we've been building here at the st.
Louis chess club we started in 2009 with
the u.s. championship next year we are
the US Women's Championship and of
course since that wasn't enough
in 2013 we added the strongest
tournament in chess the Sinquefield Cup
that wasn't enough so last year we added
the strongest tournament or females in
the entire continent with the Karen's
Cup the club has given an immense amount
of success to all of its projects and
truly the entire chess world looks at
the club when this events are going on
and that is due to the talent of
everybody that is here present from
production to the players but of course
a highlight are the ten ladies that are
here sitting with us it's been an
unbelievable nine rounds of chess a
roller coaster for many players
definitely difficult for the
commentators to make guesses but we had
wins we had losses we had only a few
draws and honestly we just had a lot of
fun this was a great tournament to cast
but I am here to introduce to you guys
the executive director and one of the
persons that really makes all of this
happen Tony without you none of this
would really be possible Tony rich thank
you very much
you know I always feel that this moment
in a tournament is bittersweet I'm very
happy that everything went very smoothly
I think the players had a great time I
know our spectators really loved the
event but it's also time to say goodbye
to the players and move on to the next
event the st. Louis chess club hosts
tournaments like the Karen's Cup or the
Sinquefield Cup or the US Championship
and the Women's Championship and the
juniors and the girls juniors and the
norm tournaments in the classics we do
all of that really to promote chess you
know st. Louis has become the capital of
chess in the country that is due in
large part in really the only reason is
because of dr. Jeanne and Rex
Sinquefield so a round of applause for
the founders of the club the club
started 12 years ago with the singular
focus of of growing the game of chess in
the United States we've been lucky to be
able to do that through major events
through scholastic chess programming
through programming in the st. Louis
community as well these events really
spotlight the top players they show you
what chess can produce the superstars
the amazing talents these brilliant
people who play the game and my hope is
that the young players from st. Louis
have had an opportunity to come by the
club see all of you play were inspired
by that and we'll be the next generation
of women who take over the chess world
so thank you all for joining us thank
you all for making it a great event and
back to you Alejandra
[Applause]
thank you Tony and traditional here at
this juncture I introduce Jenny Singh
field to be here but this is a different
tournament this is the ladies are the
stars so I get to introduce the husband
of Jeannie Singh field and somebody with
who we owe an immense amount of
gratitude for all the tournaments that
he's able to host and for all the
projects that are happening here at the
st. Louis Jessica Rex Sinquefield Thank
You alejandro
what an incredible event and what a
great tournament and what a great field
for the Karen's Cup I thank you and
complement all of you this is the
strongest female tournament on American
soil ever but it will be bettered next
year so what I I think it's fair to say
that we are truly in the presence
[Applause]
I want to thank all the players for
amazing chest fighting chess most of the
games were decisive the bottom line here
is women know how to get it done end of
story
[Applause]
now joy Bray has another version of that
but I can't I can't say that here
because it's you know this is a PG
audience so and but you made it you you
players made it great for the viewership
the online audience all around the world
and of course I have to thank the
greatest commentators of any sport in
the world
Yaser gen alejandro christian tot chav
and our russian commentators Elmyra and
what's your other name yeah yes yes I
mean all of you are really fantastic it
wasn't that funny Jennifer I forget a
lot of things what was I saying so and
yeah thank you
and I want to thank the staff at the
Chess Club Tony and the Hall of Fame and
Randy and his team Kevin and Mosel team
spectrum Studios along with the team at
silverback studios Tom and all of those
folks which do a tremendous job a
production job for the the the coverage
which is just unbelievable and as
mentioned the opening ceremony for this
tournament it's named for my wife so
it's my pleasure to introduce the
eponymous person of this tournament Jean
Karin's Sinquefield
[Applause]
you notice he didn't talk about my chess
playing ability although I do want to
say I actually helped I want I really
wanted to thank you all for coming on
Wednesday to help us teach the chest
merit badge
and I actually was good enough to help
one of the players
she was asking which way the pawns move
and I knew that way this was so much fun
before we were talking we were just
saying you know this tournaments gonna
be so much better because people play to
win they're playing to have fun last
fall the Sinquefield cup named after him
yes there was 80% draws there were under
50% draws in this tournament so how
about a hand for fighting chefs
[Applause]
[Music]
and we had some great games some upsets
yes women you know Clarissa
with black winning and beating the world
champion and lat and we had spectacular
games it was so much fun it was just so
much fun going into the end it was like
we were sort of making bets and there
were like a number of possibilities of
who was going to win this is on the last
day these are the tournaments that I
like having a little fun well okay
someone so wins and this person doesn't
win and that person does this there's
going to be a playoff and the guys in
the truck who've been working all week
or betting for not having a playoff so
it was a lot of fun and then the fun
story for me is humphy for those of you
who don't speak Hindu and aren't from
India her dad named her a Indian word is
close to Humpty that means champion so I
think she did that this time
[Applause]
but I do want to thank all of you from
coming so far away a couple of uber in
the US but the rest of you were from all
over the world Russia Ukraine Georgia
China India this has just been
spectacular thank you very much for
coming I hope to see you next year and
thank you for showing the world how much
more fun
women's chess is the next person I'm
about to introduce I really think has a
time machine when I just see how many
projects she's involved in and how she
still has time to fix Rex's openings
I am absolutely amazed please welcome
Jennifer Hadi thank you so much
Alejandra but I still have work on Rex's
openings so this tournament exceeded my
expectations even before the first pond
was pushed I mean we have three reigning
world champions including the recently
crowned
women's world champion we have three
former women's world champions and just
an incredible field I want to give a
special shout out to everybody who
helped the young people that came to the
Chess Club
whether it was signing an autograph
after a game
irena even signed an autograph after she
lost in him very gracious and everybody
who helped out at the Community Day also
as the director of women's programs at
u.s. chess I want to give a special
shout out to my American friends Chris
and Irina you guys really got rolling on
the second half so the double
round-robin starts tomorrow I also want
to give a shout out to our champion
humpy kanaru
I mean I was so impressed by her even in
that first game one thing that chess
players just dream of is making a
super-deep idea look simple it's
something that everybody raved about
that
you're dead and in her first victory she
did that and I think that game will be
remembered for many years to come
um I really also want to thank everyone
who made this tournament possible from
the sinc fields to the Chess Club to the
world chess Hall of Fame the reciting
chess is dr. Jeanne Sinquefield
mentioned but it was really emblematic
that the last game was played to King
versus King and I want to give a special
thank you to Valentina for making that
the longest second of all time and
ultimately proving to us that chess is
truly a game of Queens well now have the
great pleasure of introducing our
players to you in no particular order
I'll start from right to left and I will
give well Chris Burt will pass around
the microphones we would like to ask you
to share with us a highlight from this
tournament whether it's a positive a
negative or just a funny story it's
completely up to you
let's start with many many times US
women's champion are you gonna crush why
I think the highlight of this tournament
was probably curses come back I mean you
know yes I think that's something that's
gonna be remembered for a long time I
mean it's not easy to play and like the
strongest tournaments of your life for
the first time and and to have it start
like so it's too difficult waste a
disappointing way and then to completely
turn it around and to get like four
points from five games and it just you
know it's to me it's um it's a really
good lesson but you just got to keep
going and keep fighting and things
always have a chance to turn around oh
thank you for that
[Applause]
um so thanks for hiring but you kind of
stole my answer so the youngest okay
the Judkins International Master female
International Master from the us-korea
yep so um I guess my highlight would be
all the friends I made along the way you
know really touched my heart you know
fantastic experience I love you guys
from Georgia not a zagnut sir yeah I'm
really happy that I had the opportunity
to come back this year yeah and okay
I'm not satisfied with my play but I'm
really happy and grateful what you were
doing for a moment just here so I hope I
will have in the future opportunity to
come back and play here again and show
my best because I just am not satisfied
this year
and from India hydro Valley I don't know
what her highlight of the tournament
because I'm in my own world from the day
one like suffering with Viral and at
some point I started imagining things
that I have some virus and I will pass
on to everyone in the club from every
everyone and then I after my game I
asked us someone in the staff for if I
can see a doctor and I was so touched
John took me specially to the hospital
he stayed there for two hours and Rex
took care of my medical expenses and
they did everything to make sure that I
am fine and this is something very
touching moment for me
and I'm really really glad first of all
I didn't give any virus to anyone and I
survived and I think I'm the happiest
moment was when when the doctor told
that I'm fine and I'm like you know
without virus so that was my happiest
moment in this tournament and I'm really
touched by the way everything is
arranged the way they take care of the
players and everything it feels really
special and I would like to say one
thing last time I love this tournament
so much but I had some illustrating and
I wanted to make sure that I am in the
tournament I wanted to gain rating I
want to be on top and I gained 50 points
to be there on the in this tournament
and now to be stronger next time I don't
know how much rating I have to gain next
year but definitely I will I love I'll
try to come back and thank you so much
for everything and lovely tournament and
I put I hope it continues
and somebody that hopefully disagrees
with that virus passing around Katrina
LACMA yes even well I didn't show the
best chef here I wanted to show but
still I'm very happy to play to have
some new experience
it was nice tournament for me with ups
and downs and but anyway I'm very glad
and thanks to everybody and I want to
congratulate the winners girls who are
really strong well hope to be back next
year I hope to be on top to be here next
year okay thank you and see you
hopefully next year on our world
champion gee when Jim about my highlight
I think is that everything that I try to
have some fighting mode and try to play
my best in every game and it's very
strong and very nice tournament I really
enjoy play chess in here and many things
thank you
former women's world champion Mario
musici
I had a great time here actually I liked
almost everything here and I want to say
thanks to the organizers for making such
a strong event also I felt the support
from my friends who are currently
studying here like you Pat of Alexander
and God
she's currently in this hole yeah
hopefully next year it will be even
stronger yes I really like to play games
and strong players
ok thanks once again and hopefully next
year I would be here again and all of
you we might be able to guess her
highlight camara humpy so may know what
you guessed definitely my highlight is
like the bell ringing before the game
because I always believed that chess is
a very silent sport and starting a game
with the bell ring was quite shocking
when I started off but yes definitely it
was fun I really enjoyed playing here
and this was one of the best best
tournament the strength-wise and the
organisation wise and also the prize
money the funding everything was was it
was the world's best event and I have to
thank both of you for supporting the
human chess and I see there is a lot of
future for the US chess with your
support I can we have an example right
down here she has done fantastic in the
second half of the tournament um I also
take the opportunity Trank mr. Tony
because it was just because of your
efforts that I was here it was not at
all my plan to play this year but then
he made all the efforts to make me come
so I have to thank you for doing that
thank you very much and former women's
world champion Alexander castaigne well
the highlight of this tournament for me
was definitely coming back and white I
mean getting an invitation for the
second time in a row because as Haruka
mentioned it's definitely this
tournament became such a strong
motivation and but alas I lost so many
rating points last year so it was out of
reach this top-10 and I couldn't you
know couldn't do anything in my power to
get them back the points but when I got
an invitation finally I was so happy and
delighted and I needed to completely
change my plans and lost some tickets
and but I did really care because it's
such a wonderful tournament I mean I
fell in love with it
once I mean the second it was announced
two years ago and the second I heard
about the first edition I gladly
accepted it and I was just dreaming to
come here again for the second one and
dreams do come true so it was nice and
wonderful and yes it's definitely my
motivation to get back to the top ten to
be able to be invited again to get
invited again and say thank you of
course Jean and Rex it's just really a
great tournament for women's chess a
great promotion for women yes well we do
our best to make it entertaining and
just just I hope to see this tradition
flourish in the future and many more
players will come and enjoy this great
event thank you
and the winner from last year
Valentina Goo Nina to say sorry about my
English what I'm going to tell you I've
never been laughed like before in my
life as in this tournament I got so many
compliments like Valentina just hold on
you know just everything is fine and
thanks to my friends just fun and just
like it was so amazing to animal okay
sometimes you play so bad sometimes it's
really you want women better game think
of organisators and think is that you
love me so much well thank you certainly
a pleasure to have all of you with us
here in this tournament but it is time
to announce the winners so I would like
to invite Rex and ginseng field to come
here with me so we have our top three
all right all right coming in third
place edging out her opponent on tight
bricks which was direct encounter
Alexandra Christine you
[Applause]
and second place current world champion
jus in June and now for the winner of
the 2020 Caryn's Cup humpy Janeiro
[Applause]
[Applause]
Thank You Rex Thank You Jean
of course there are the stars of the
show but personally I would like to
thank a lot of people that make this a
show and an event and somebody that
really they're just a pleasure to work
with from production to my fellow
commentators Jennifer hottie and yasser
sarah 1 thank you for correcting all of
my mistakes of course our live audience
commentators christian kerala i'm
deborah habían and of course our russian
commentator so that we can be absolutely
global Almere script chenko and nasa
Karlovic and i always say that the
arbiters are doing a great job when we
don't hear about them so let's give a
big round of applause to our arbiters
Chris Berg and Nastya Sorokina
surely it's been a pleasure to be with
all of you this has been a great event
my name is Alejandro Ramirez and I'm
signing off here at the end of the 2020
Harris Cup thank you all for joining us
and we'll see you in 2021
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]